alors ça c'est une une vidéo qui a été
tournée au cimetière de Pantin aller des
sycomores division 50 le 23 mai 2023 à
9h28 donc c'était après que c'était le
lendemain de la publication de ma vidéo
d'accord et c'est toujours surtout le
lendemain du démenti de Paul Simon don
et le démenti assez violent d'ailleurs
de la ville de Paris qu'est-ce qu'on
voit sur cette sur cette vidéo on voit
une pelleteuse de la ville de Paris avec
un agent de la ville de Paris fossoyeur
de la municipale qui
ramasse et on va le voir assez
rapidement qui ramasse
des ossements qu'ils trouvent dans les
pellets de terre que la pelleteuse sort
de la fosse et
et pose ensuite au sol voilà donc là il
y a un os qui cherche quelque chose
qu'on récupère assez bien je pense qu'il
y a assez peu de doute sur la nature de
l'opérateur
et ensuite on voit dans une deuxième
partie que vous n'avez pas là toujours
dans cette opération d'exhumation
l'agent déposait les ossements dans le
reliquaire qui est censé être qui est
prévu pour pour recueillir les ossements
le problème c'est que cette pratique là
elle est absolument illégale que
normalement les fossoyeurs ont tous les
cimetières de France sont censés
utiliser l'appelleteuse pour déblayer la
terre qui a au dessus du corps en
général c'est un mètre un mètre 50 de
terre et ensuite poursuivre le travail à
l'appel et à la main notamment pour pour
le pour retirer les ossements de la
sépulture et les placer dans le
reliquaire tout ça doit se faire très
encadrer et ça doit se faire euh dans le
respect de la dignité du corps et avec
des sens alors là on est sur une un cas
d'exhumation à la pelleteuse ça a été
confirmé c'est pas moi qui le dis
c'était confirmé par trois agents du
cimetière de Pantin un que nous avons
reçu sur que vous avez reçu sur ce
plateau un autre agent qui a filmé cette
vidéo et qui a témoigné un visage enfin
de façon anonyme dans un dans un dans un
média et qui est et qui est tout à fait
clair sur la nature de l'opération alors
elle a toujours la mairie de Paris et
notamment revenue sur cette affaire il
annonce que vous que la Ville de Paris
va décider de porter plainte contre vous
regardez je veux remercier les uns et
les autres sur les différents bancs dans
tous les groupes de notre assemblée qui
m'ont fait passer des messages de
soutien
absolument
scandalisé face aux mensonges devant
laquelle nous sommes oui la ville de
Paris a décidé de porter plainte contre
Monsieur lycien les désaccords
politiques que nous pouvons avoir sont
légitimes y compris la vigilance la part
de l'opposition ce qui est normal
n'autorise pas tout n'autorise pas les
mensonges les manipulations et
n'autorise pas la diffamation
il vous accuse surtout d'avoir
délibérément menti ou déformer
l'information d'avoir des fake news et
le détail ce que vous auriez fait
regardez et vous pourrez
de reprendre une histoire qui se
trouvait dans la presse de caniveau
c'est son choix il a inséré des images
plus ancienne ou d'un autre lieu ou d'un
autre contexte que celle d'une
exhumation puis des images dérobées qui
ne qui n'illustrer absolument pas les
opérations
funéraires qu'elles étaient censées
illustrer jusqu'à si le sujet était
moins grave on pourrait en sourire des
images trouvées sur YouTube par un
chasseur de trésors intitulé Les plus
belles trouvailles de nos forêts ce sont
des techniques manipulatoires on est
donc face à un comportement de faussaire
alors bon il donne des éléments
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez lui répondre
d'abord revenir un peu sur le Conseil de
Paris que j'ai suivi en direct je suis
pas je siège pas dans cette assemblée ça
avait tout l'air d'une sorte de procès
stalinien vous savez où
tout est couru d'avance et où finalement
la parole n'est pas à la défense
évidemment et on fait dire à l'accusé ce
qu'il n'a pas dit et ce qu'il n'a pas
fait en l'occurrence je voudrais qu'on
repasse quand même les choses dans le
dans le dans le contexte et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis ici ce soir
je suis conseiller régional donc je suis
élu et je suis saisi à ce titre par des
agents trois agents qui m'informent que
des faits graves délictueux choquants
mais surtout pénalement répréhensible
sont on court dans un cimetière qui est
géré par la Ville de Paris je prends ce
témoignage et j'essaye de voir s'il y a
des éléments qui viennent les payer qui
viennent corroborer ces déclarations et
je trouve des éléments
entendu parler la dernière fois il y a
des procès-verbaux de l'inspection
générale de la ville de Paris avec des
témoignages d'agents qui évoquent dès
septembre 2022 les exhumations à la
pelleteuse et l'usage des pelleteuses
sur les exhumations administratives il y
a ensuite des vidéos vous en avez
diffusé une il y en a une deuxième qui
sont assez édifiantes et qui laisse
assez peu de place au doute donc moi si
vous voulez et par ailleurs on a appris
dans Le Parisien en fin de semaine
dernière que les syndicats tirés la
sonnette d'alarme et dénoncer les
pressions de la hiérarchie pour que les
agents témoignent dans le sens de la
ville et pas de sous silence les
accusations que je pouvais que je
pouvais formuler
ma responsabilité
ma responsabilité en tant que élu c'est
dès lors que j'ai connaissance de tels
agissements c'est deux choses d'abord de
saisir la justice et je vais vous dire
c'est pas un luxe ni un confort c'est
une obligation
un élu dès lors qu'il est informé de fée
délictueux doit saisir le procureur de
la République si je ne fais pas ça je
suis potentiellement je peux être
potentiellement mis en cause pour ne pas
avoir dénoncé ce que j'ai su et ce qui
était corroboré par des éléments donc je
saisis le procureur de la République en
lui donnant tous ces éléments-là pour
qu'ils puissent ouvrir une enquête parce
que je souhaite que la transparence soit
faite et l'ensemble mais surtout de
cette affaire au deuxième chose c'est la
vidéo qu'on a vu tout à l'heure je donne
la parole à ce témoin cette agent
municipal lanceur d'alerte peut-être
pourrions de l'appeler qui me délivre
son témoignage et dans quel but dans le
but d'alerter d'alerter la mairie
d'alerter l'opinion et surtout de lancer
un débat de lancer un débat et je pense
aussi que là c'est ma responsabilité de
lui de dire que à partir du moment où il
y a des éléments qui sont accablants et
qui viennent corroborer des accusations
qui sont très graves c'est la
responsabilité de l'É que je suis que de
lancer ce débat la polémique la
controverse en tout cas le débat
démocratique et c'était ça que nous
servons si j'avais fermé les yeux sur ce
qui s'y passait j'aurai une
responsabilité aux yeux de la loi merci
on ne voulait avoir votre votre
bien sûr travailler sur ce qui a été dit
au Conseil de Paris on va juste revenir
sur un extrait sur lui Paul Simondon
vous auriez tout fait pour
propager des fake news pour un ticket
chez Hanouna merci Paul voilà ils
peuvent venir aussi s'exprimer Paul
Simoneau
alors plus fausse les unes que les
autres et pourquoi pour un ticket chez
Hanouna c'est ça c'est ça le l'objectif
mais à quel prix parce qu'il y a bien
des conséquences des familles inquiètes
meurtri qui nous sollicite et on les
comprend elles ont droit à la sérénité
sur ce lieu où repose l'un de leurs
proches alors vous êtes sûr de vous
je suis je suis à la lumière des entiers
non ça m'inquiète pas je vous dis
c'était couru d'avance moi en fait ce
qui ce que je trouve dommageable c'est
que cette plainte elle a
vraisemblablement très peu de chances
d'aboutir cette plainte en diffamation
elle n'a qu'un seul objectif c'est ce
qu'on appelle une procédure baillon
c'est-à-dire que c'est de l'intimidation
pour faire taire celles et ceux qui et
ça pourrait avoir envie de témoigner
davantage j'ai une question pour
l'instant pierre il y a pas de problème
il enquête il a des témoignages etc mais
c'est normal que la mairie de Paris
réagisse moi ce qui me gêne c'est qu'à
partir de d'image qui au départ n'était
pas du tout représentatif de ce que vous
dénonciez et ça vous l'avez reconnu vous
en faites une affaire comme s'il y avait
une opération concertée illégale
permanente de la Mairie de Paris moi
c'est ça qui me gêne il y a peut-être eu
un ou deux ratés mais de là à tomber
comme ça sur la mairie de Paris moi je
trouve que peut-être vous exagérez un
peu j'entends ce que vous dites il se
trouve que les les on a su par la suite
des témoignages d'agent dans par voie de
presse qui ont expliqué en fait cette
procédure d'exhumation à la pelleteuse
c'était finalement la voix normale de
l'exhumation donc moi je pose simplement
une question j'aimerais que la lumière
soit faite est-ce que c'est des faits
qui sont
l'acte des actes isolés de d'agents
zélés ou peu scrupuleux ou est-ce que
c'est systémique je pose la question
j'ai le droit en tant que élu et même en
tant que citoyen de poser la question et
demander à la ville de Paris de rendre
des comptes je il est normal que la
Ville de Paris prenne une décision et
peut-être même porte plainte parce que
encore une fois ce sont des faits qui
sont pénalement répréhensibles mais
pourquoi porter plainte contre moi
pourquoi ne pas porter plainte contre X
pour que justement le procureur se
saisisse de cette affaire efface toute
la lumière et porter plainte contre X
constitution de partie civils si jamais
il y a eu
des actes comme ça qui sont
répréhensibles la justice fera son
travail c'est en ça que je m'étonne de
la procédure de la ville d'autant plus
qu'elle a ces éléments là que ces
éléments là ont suscité beaucoup
d'inquiétude et que la responsabilité de
la ville de Paris c'est justement de
faire la transparence le seul argument
que vous avez entendu ce soir le seul
argument que j'ai entendu en conseil de
Paris hier quant au différents éléments
et aux accusations que j'ai et que j'ai
pu relayer c'est un argument d'autorité
qui consiste à dire que tout cela est
faux mais moi ça ne me suffit pas ça
peut ça peut passer en conseil de Paris
dans une assemblée politique ça ne passe
pas devant un juge